when you look at someone you been doing
this for a long time how do you know
what they would be if you painted their
face like how do you decide what you do
they ask for something or do you use
your creativity and figure out this is
what you should be it's kind of like a
give-and-take sometimes you ask do you
want to look nice or spooky mm-hmm and
then sometimes you ask all what's your
favorite animal and then sometimes
people let you go totally crazy and just
Surprise them right if you were to
assign me an animal what would I be I
think like definitely some sort of
feline cat yeah be a cat right that
would be that coming really scary yeah
you would be such a spooky cat right so
kind of a creepy
thank you like a giraffe so I'd be
that's you've just described a freak you
just described an animal that wants to
be put out of its misery cat half
giraffe constantly in pain right is that
what you're saying well it's a new
paradigm that we're in you know I think
we should really embrace strange I'm
told I know we don't have a lot of time
but I'm told you brought some face pain
I do
quickly what would you do you have a
crack right now at this puss right here
this beautiful face and go for it make
me a feline whatever you want to do
whatever you're feeling I'm feeling it
I'm gonna feel it out here okay this is
acid
and they don't tell me these things
before the show no I think it's best
that they not and just just so you know
this is a life choice okay that's all
right I can live with this no this isn't
gonna hurt so just gently close your
eyes okay how you start all right this
is total trust right now go home yeah
okay you're at all okay lean how lean
you're taller than most children yeah
yes you may put your hand on that
germophobe no I'm not
I like the touching and I love the
caressing oh my gosh wait wait why did
you touch my hair and go oh my god
people at home now I think it's like
polyurethane that's real hair right
there I'm collecting your DNA okay okay
so close your eyes no you actually can't
move your mouth for a second no it's
gonna be hard but
[Music]
you're doing great you're doing so great
you can move your mouth is so
condescending I just that you're say I'm
doing great when I sit absolutely still
you know it's actually a really hard
thing for people to do especially boys
but you know the women's March was
yesterday it's time for the boys to be
still and quiet can we do this for a
while
define awhile okay wait could I do one
more thing yeah sure okay okay here we
go
because I mentioned a giraffe hold on
hold on I'm feeling this is the calmest
I've ever been on my show oh my gosh
what are you drawing on the side is that
a scar what is that well your audience's
price you know compiled
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hating wicked your cat and address this
is the this is I would like could keep
this I'm gonna have this tattooed over
yeah and wear this every night from now
on for the rest of my life so thank you
very much and your solo in my life
you